salts delicious as heck it goes great on
fries chips soups and all kinds of
savory items but salt and desserts you
don't think about it so why does salt
work so so so well sprinkled on top of
chocolate chip cookies seriously try it
well one reason it works so dang good is
cuz sugar is tasty and salt is tasty
so you layer one good flavor on another
and you got a lot of good business going
on duh but that's not the whole story
salt is special because it isn't just
tasty it has taste enhancing qualities
what does that mean
adults have hundreds of thousands of
taste receptor cells that live primarily
on our tongues though they also live in
the intestines browse some of these
receptors become activated when we eat
something sugary but if you add sodium
into the equation some of these sweet
receptors that don't normally activate
when we have just sugar become alert
this intensifies the sugar to get this
double punch of sweetness a pinch of
salt is all you need so get to pinching
cookie lovers
you